The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: So
last time, we were
talking about the standard model
as an effective field theory.
And we decided that
the power counting
would be this, epsilon,
the masses of the particles
in the standard model, the
scales in the standard model
divided by some new
physics scale, scale
outside the standard model.
And I made the
statement that this
was connected to
operator dimension,
but I didn't make that precise.
And I want to do that now as
the first thing we do today.
So let's spend a
few minutes and talk
about marginal, irrelevant,
and relevant operators
and their connection
to power counting.
I'm going to write power
counting over and over again.
And I'm going to
abbreviate it p.c.
from now on.
So let's consider an
effective field theory.
It'll be a scalar effective
field theory in d dimensions,
standard kinetic term,
mass term, phi 4 term.
So it'll be a phi 4
scalar field theory.
It will be an effective
theory, so we won't stop there.
And I'll just write
down up to phi 6.
And then, in principle,
I could keep going.
So we can look at the dimensions
of the various objects here.
The action with our
units is dimensionless.
h bar and c are 1.
So the mass dimensions of
the field in d dimensions
are d minus 2 over 2 since the
dimensions of ddx or minus d.
We have to compensate for that.
And we have to compensate
for the two derivatives.
The canonically
normalized kinetic term
tells us what the
dimensions of phi are.
And then we can work out the
dimensions of everything else,
so mass squared dimension 2.
Tau dimension-- 6 minus 2d.
Lambda could be
dimension 0 if d is 4.
OK.
So hopefully-- somewhat
familiar stuff.
So let's say we want
to study a correlation
function of a bunch of phis at
different space time points.
And we want to look at
it at long distance.
Long distance is small momenta.
So the way I'm going to
make the distance long
is I'm going to say that all
these x's that are appearing
in my phis, x1
through xn, I'm going
to redefine them as some s
common parameter times x prime.
And then I'm just going to take
s goes to infinity with the x
prime fixed.
So that makes all the x's large.
So when I do that, if I make
a redefinition like that,
I can mess up the normalization
of my kinetic term.
It'll no longer be
canonical, but I can fix that
by just redefining my field.
And the way to do that
is to do the following.
To find a new, phi prime,
it's equal to the old field,
but rescaled by an s.
And the outcome
of that is that we
get an action for the
phi prime field written
in terms of prime coordinates,
which has a kinetic term that's
the same form.
But then s's start showing
up in the other places.
And if you look at the powers
of the s's that are showing up,
it's related also to the
powers of these parameters.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you sure about
the powers of lambda tau,
for the dimension lambda tau?
IAIN STEWART: Did
I get it backwards?
Should it be d minus 4?
AUDIENCE: I think it
should be d minus 4.
And then the other one should
be d minus 6 [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
That looks right.
Oh, you have to be--
so let's see.
There's d's here, right?
So it's not d.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
IAIN STEWART:
You've got to keep--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I stick by what I wrote.
Check it.
All right, so let's look at the
correlation function in terms
of the phi prime because
the phi prime is just
a function of x primes.
And the x primes
are holding fixed.
So if we rescale everything
in terms of the x primes,
then we have some matrix element
that's not growing with s.
We can make all
the s's explicit.
So we take our
original guy, which
in terms of our new
variables looks like that.
We make this redefinition.
We get some powers
of s out front.
And then we get something which
is just in terms of the x prime
and won't grow with s.
So we can study this in various
dimensions if we wanted to.
Let's, for simplicity and also
since it's the most common case
we're interested
in, take d equals 4.
I still may write d's, but let's
from here on take d equals 4
and ask the question, what
happens is s gets large?
So now, we've made
all the s's explicit.
This is something that
you often do when you're
doing effective field theory.
You can figure out how
you're going to study
the large distance behavior.
You want to make
the parameter that's
controlling that limit
explicit, so you can see it.
So it's not hiding anywhere.
And that's what we've
done with this algebra.
So as s goes to
infinity, because we
have this explicit
s squared there,
the m squared term is becoming
more and more important.
It's called relevant.
Child term is becoming
less important.
Because if I put in d equals 4,
then this is s to the minus 2.
It's tracking the s's, making
it less important as s grows.
And the lambda term is equally
as important as it was before.
And the terminology that
goes along with this
is an association.
So that was a statement
about parameters.
We could also make a
statement about operators
since obviously they were
part of the story here
that gave the s factors.
So we would say that phi
squared is a relevant operator.
The phi 4 is marginal.
And phi 6 is irrelevant.
And you can see, because of
the argument that we made,
that this was just directly
connected to dimension,
so either to the
dimension of the operators
or to the dimension
of the parameters.
OK, so we're connecting
something that we can say,
which is the power counting.
In this case, we're
controlling that
with s using s as our
control parameters
to look at long distances.
And we're seeing that
that gets connected
to dimensions of operators.
Is there any questions?
So let's take s
finite, but large.
Usually, we're not
interested in taking
it all the way to infinity.
Although we may make
it as large as we
want to study some
long distance behavior.
And so what I just said
is that we can see,
from the powers of
s, the importance
of the various terms.
Relevant terms are more
important than marginal terms.
And marginal terms are more
important than irrelevant
terms.
The words say it all.
So that means that, if you want
to think of how to do the power
counting and you don't want to
think of introducing this s,
since that was kind
of just our choice--
we introduced it as a way of
thinking about this question.
But if we went back to
the original action,
we should have a way of
doing the power counting
from that without having
to do this rescaling.
And we know how to do that now.
This exercise teaches
us that we can just
look at mass dimensions
of the parameters
to do the power counting.
So if we just associate a
power to the parameters,
we're still in d equals 4.
Then we would get
this association,
this being the statement
that it's relevant, marginal,
and irrelevant.
And we can do a power
counting in this lambda nu.
And we can then say,
in a language which
would be familiar
from Feynman diagrams
where we do everything
in momentum space,
that the momentum
we want to study,
p, has to be much less
than this lambda nu.
And we'll do the power
counting to lambda nu.
And that will make the,
for example, tau term
an irrelevant, less
important, operator.
So there's one comment here.
We did the scalar field theory
just because it's simplest.
It also has a relevant operator.
And we see that relevant
operators actually
can be dangerous
because we'd like
to set the power counting
for the whole problem
by the kinetic term.
We'd like to say that
the kinetic term, which
was canonically normalized
and had no s's in it,
we'd like to say that
that was relevant,
that that's part of the
leading order Lagrangian.
But when we went through
it, we found something that
was more relevant, the master.
Phi squared could become even
larger than the kinetic term.
So we have to be careful
about relevant operators.
And then this is, of course,
related to the Higgs fine
tuning.
So even though I'm using
a scalar field theory,
I'm, for the most part, going
to just fine tune and ignore
this problem, since if I was
using something fermionic field
theory, I could
set things up so I
could ignore it from the start.
But still using a scalar
field theory is convenient.
So I want to also come
back to something else
that we mentioned last time and
go into a little more detail.
And that is the
discussion of divergences.
So last time, we
said that there was
two different ways of thinking
about renormalizability,
a traditional sense
of renormalizability,
renormalizability of
the standard model,
or an effective field
theory way of thinking
about renormalizability.
So I want to come back to that
with our example of this scalar
field theory.
So let's get rid of this
issue of having something that
can upset the power
counting either
by taking m to be 0 or just
fine tuning it to be small.
And what that means is I
just demand that, as s grows,
I shrink m.
And if I do that, then I can,
by hand, tune term and this term
to be the same size.
So if you like, I'm
assigning a scaling
to m in order to make the
mass term be always as
important as the kinetic term.
So with that little
proviso, we can start
thinking about divergences.
And when we start
drawing Feynman diagrams,
they will generically
have divergences.
So we could have two
four-point interactions,
which I label by lambda, because
that's the parameter that
shows up in the Feynman rule.
If this is k and this
is some k plus p,
then this guy is going to
have two pairs of lambda.
And it's going to be
some integral like that.
We won't worry about
overall factors here.
I'm regulating with
dimensional regularization.
I'll often do that when
it's convenient for us.
If you ask how this
integral diverges,
you could ask how
it diverges just
in terms of thinking about it in
terms of some parameter that's
controlling the
ultraviolet, like a cutoff.
So even if I am using dim
reg, I could ask, what's
the power of the divergence?
And it diverges as, in
d dimensions, lambda
to d minus 4.
You say d minus 4 is the
degree of the divergence.
And that's because you have d
powers of k from the measure
and minus 4 from
the propagators.
So if d is equal to 4, you
say degree of divergence is 0,
but that means log diversion.
So if you take d equals 4 in a
UV, 4 powers of k downstairs,
d upstairs-- but
if d is 4, that's
4 upstairs and 4 downstairs.
So it's scaling
length dk over k.
So I made it Euclidean.
That's exactly what
it would become.
And that's like a log.
So it's a log of the cut off.
So it's a 1 over
epsilon in dim reg
where d is 4 minus 2 epsilon.
And if you just want to
think about what this does,
well, it's something that
renormalizes the lambda phi 4
operator.
So you need a counter
term for the lambda phi 4.
So you add to your
theory that counter term.
And you could get rid
of this divergence.
OK.
So, so far-- hopefully
standard stuff.
Let's keep going, think
about other diagrams.
So what if I put in a tau
term and a lambda term?
This integral is
the same integral.
I just have different
fields on the outside.
So it's got the same
divergence, but now
the operator it's
renormalizing is an operator
with 6 points on the outside.
So it's renormalizing
the tau phi 6 term.
So I insert one
tau and one lambda,
and I have to get back the
renormalization of tau.
Well, that's not so bad.
We had tau from the start, if
we include the tau term, so not
really a problem from
the point of view
of a standard
renormalization program.
But we could also include
two taus, like this, again,
same integral, so
same divergence.
And now, this
renormalizes something
that we haven't included yet,
something with 8 points a phi 8
operator.
So in order to
renormalize that diagram
and make the theory
renormalizable
and an effective
field theory sense,
we need to include
the phi 8 operator.
So if I'd ignored the
dots that I wrote down--
so let me say,
without the dots--
then phi 8 wasn't there.
And so then, therefore, I
would say the theory is not
renormalizable.
That's what makes the
tau operator the phi 6
operator via non-renormalizable
theory in the traditional sense
if we include that operator.
That's the classic
way of thinking.
And the effective
theory way of thinking
is just that we have
to add that operator
as soon as this diagram
would become relevant.
So we just determined
a minute ago
that tau goes like
lambda nu to the minus 2.
So tau goes like 1
over lambda nu squared.
And in this diagram, we
have two powers of tau.
So it's even less important.
So lambda nu to the fourth--
downstairs.
And so when it becomes
relevant to us,
we want that kind
of accuracy that we
want to include things that
go like 1 over lambda nu
to the fourth.
We have to consider
this diagram.
And we have to consider
adding that operator
to the effective theory.
And that's the sense in which
we say that the theory can
be renormalized order by order
in its power kinetic parameter,
which is 1 over lambda nu.
So I could order this order, but
we have to add this operator.
OK?
Make sense?
Silence means that
it makes sense.
Jumping up and down saying
it doesn't make sense
means that it doesn't make
sense or puzzled looks
from everybody, but
that's harder to discern.
So we can summarize this way of
thinking in the following way.
Remember with the
effective theory
that we're only
interested in computing
things to some accuracy.
And the accuracy controls
where we stop in the series.
So if we're interested in
stopping at lambda nu to the r
or 1 over s to
the r-- s was big.
And lambda nu is also
much bigger than the p.
But let's stick to
talking about lambda nu.
And we include all operators
that have dimensions up
to a certain level.
And since the power counting
is connected to dimensions,
we're kind of guaranteed that
we will have everything we need.
So as I promised, what this
little argument or discussion
tells us, is how power counting
is connected to dimensions.
And this is the classic way of
thinking about effective field
theory is that the
power counting is
connected to dimensions.
So this seems pretty
generic actually.
You could imagine that,
if I did scalars, I mean,
fermions and scalars
of gauge theory,
then I could still go through
the same type of arguments,
write down higher
dimensional operators,
go through all these arguments.
And so it seems
that I'd actually
shown you something more
powerful than what I claimed.
Because I said, here, it seems
like it's almost this, right,
that power counting is always
connected to dimensions.
So can anyone spot where there
was an assumption in what we
did that where in some case the
power counting might not have
been related to dimensions?
It's a tough question.
AUDIENCE: If the power
counting isn't a ratio scale?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
But I want a little bit
more than that, right track.
So going back to this
example that we did,
what did we assume at the
beginning that led us here?
AUDIENCE: That we
changed the mass point?
IAIN STEWART: No, the mass
wasn't so much the issue.
So what it was is that we
scaled all the coordinates
by the same amount.
We said all the coordinates are
getting large in the same way.
And we could have done something
more complicated than that.
We could have said some
components of this coordinate
are getting larger, faster
than other components.
That's what you do in a
non-relativistic theory
where the time component
and the spatial coordinates
would scale in different ways.
So that was the assumption.
We assumed, basically, that
everything was getting large.
All the coordinates were
getting large uniformly with s.
And we said x mu i was
equal to s x prime mu i.
With a universal s for
all the components,
that was an assumption
that led us here.
And we may not always do that.
In fact, in some of our
examples, we won't do that.
But here, for the
standard model,
that's what you want to do.
So if we have the standard
model, which is just L0,
the usual standard
model, then we
know, as part of the
way of constructing it,
that we wrote down all the
operators with dimension
less than or equal to 4.
And we also know that
it was renormalizable
in a traditional sense.
So now, let's talk
about the standard model
corrections, i.e. terms
in the standard model
from an effective field
theory point of view
that are operators we
can write down, like L1.
So L1, I can write it in the
following way, which is kind
of a convenient thing to do.
Pull out the scale lambda nu.
Leave over some
dimensionless constant.
So I'll just use some scale
lambda nu for all the operators
that I consider.
And I'll just allow
for differences
between the various
scales that the operators
could have to be taken up
by dimensionless constants.
And O5 here is a
dimension 5 operator.
The dimension of c is 0.
In a power counting notation,
we say c is of order 1.
That means that we
don't count any powers
of lambda nu associated to c.
What we've done here is we've
made the power explicit by just
writing it in.
So that's often convenient
just in the same way
it was convenient to make the
s's explicit in that argument.
Now, we're just building up the
theory, writing down operators,
making the lambda nu's,
which are our power counting
parameter, very explicit.
Now, the statement that,
in the standard model,
it was renormalizable in
the traditional sense,
I told you that what that meant
is that nothing in lambda 0,
nothing in Lagrangian 0, really
tells us about lambda nu.
So we're free to take
it as big as we want.
There's no constraint on it from
our leading order Lagrangian.
In particular, we can
take it much bigger
than things like the
taught mass or the w mass.
And we can make these
corrections as small
as we want.
So L1 is, therefore, really
we can think of it as really
giving some small corrections.
And we can adjust how small
they are by just dialing up
the scale of lambda nu.
All right, so let's
get down to business
and actually talk about
what this Lagrangian is.
Our notation that we index the
Lagrangian in a series, this
is our sum over n that we
talked about last time.
And our power counting
is that we associated
this guy here with no
powers of lambda nu,
this guy here with
one inverse power,
this guy here with two
inverse power, et cetera.
And we want to think about
using this for some p, which you
could say is of
order m top squared,
some scale that's much
less than the lambda nu.
It could be larger than on top.
It could be 10 TeV,
whatever we decide.
But it's just, in order
for me to write something
on the board, let
me write m top.
OK.
So how do we
construct L1 and L2?
What do we assume?
Well, one thing we assume,
or we are free to assume
and is a reasonable
assumption, is
that there are not going to be
any Lorentz invariant or gauge
invariant violating terms.
OK.
So we can maintain these as
symmetries of our theory.
So we assume that
they're unbroken.
So that means,
when we write down
these L1 and L2, or
generically each Li,
that we're going to have to do
it by writing down operators
that are gauge invariant.
Even though they're
higher dimension,
we still have to satisfy gauge
variance of the standard model
and Lorentz invariance.
So that's going to
restrict what we can do.
We also construct Li from
the same degrees of freedom
that we have in L0.
So we know what fields to use.
So that's important.
It means that, once you've
got the leading order
effective field
theory, you know where
to go for the higher order
terms because you're just
using the same fields.
I'll also make the assumption
that the Higgs vacuum
expectation value is going to
stay to be the value in L0.
So the way that the gauge group
is broken by the Higgs vacuum
expectation value is
spontaneously broken.
We're not going
to mess with that.
And we built into this
idea that we do this
because there's no new particles
that are produced at p.
If there was a new
particle produced at p,
then they would have
to have a mass that
would allow us to produce it.
And that would mean that
it doesn't have a mass up
at this lambda nu scale.
And we'd have to include it
in our effective Lagrangian.
So by taking this
point of view, we're
assuming that there's
no new particles that
are produced at the scale
p, only at lambda nu.
And effectively,
we've integrated out,
if you want to use that
language-- although we're
doing this from the bottom up.
If you wanted to have
a top-down language,
you'd say we integrated
out the particles
at the scale lambda nu.
OK, so that's our logic.
So let me just start seeing
what we can write down.
And for the dimension 5, it's
actually very restrictive.
Gauge symmetry is very
restrictive for dimension 5.
And there's basically
only one operator.
So we won't stop at dimension 5.
We'll go up to the dimension 6.
At dimension 5, it turns
out that, once you satisfy
the gauge symmetry, the unique
term that you can write down
looks like this.
And my notation is
that this guy is
our left-handed lepton with a
charge conjugation operator.
And these guys are doublets.
So the Higgs doublet
is a doublet like that.
And the left-handed leptons,
neutrino, an electron
is a doublet like that.
So these are doublets.
And I'm figuring out how to
contract with doublet indices,
but I have to satisfy the U1
hyper charged gauge invariance.
This has no color.
So that's automatically
satisfied.
And then I have to
satisfy the SU2.
And I've done that by
the way that the indices
are contracted.
One thing I didn't write
down in this operator
is flavor indices.
So if you were to
add flavor indices,
you could do a bit more.
But in some sense, that's a
pretty simple generalization.
So we'll still count it as
one even though we could think
about having more flavors.
We're contracting things
with more flavors.
And that would, of
course, affect arguments
made on gauge symmetry alone.
So in all my
counting today, I'll
be agnostic about
flavor matrices.
So when I say only, that
proviso is hidden there, OK?
So this guy is
kind of interesting
from an phenomenological
point of view.
Because if you replace the Higgs
field by its vacuum expectation
value, which means
getting rid of H+ ?
And taking h0 to be a
constant, which is v,
then that gives a
Majorana mass term.
So the observed
left-handed neutrino
would get a term
in its Lagrangian
that, after we do that,
it looks like that.
And that's a Majorana
mass term, where
this m nu is a
parameter that shows up,
but it's built out of
the parameters that
were in this thing.
So once I replace
these by [INAUDIBLE]
and go through the
various factors,
we get something like that.
So just the fact that we know
that the observed neutrino
masses are less
than, say, 3.5 eV
tells us something
about the scale.
So this is small.
If c5 is of order 1, I
told you we know what v is.
It's 246 GeV.
That tells us something about
lambda nu that it's big.
But we could try to
think up some reasons
why the c5 maybe have
some suppression in it
and make the c a
little bit smaller.
But if C5 is order 1, then
we get a very large lambda nu
scale.
I'll give you a problem on
your problem set to explore
this in a little more detail.
I should also note that the
Majorana mass term, having
two neutrinos like this,
violates lepton number, which
is a global symmetry of the
standard model, at least
classically.
So this guy violates
lepton numbers.
You can also write down
dimension 6 operators
that violate baryon number.
And I'm going to leave that,
also, as a problem set problem.
So you'll figure out
what those operators are.
So example 3, if I conserve
lepton number and baryon
number--
which are things that,
if they're broken,
that's obviously
having a big impact.
And there's obviously
strong constraints on that.
So you can ask then, if
you go to dimension 6
and we conserve those
things because they're
highly constrained, how many
operators are there left over?
And there's 80.
So L2, we can account exactly
how many operators there are.
And there's i from 1 to 80, some
coefficients and some operators
that are dimension 6.
And if I'm going to make
a lambda nu explicit,
I put a lambda nu
squared in there.
So 80 sounds like a big number,
but big is always relative.
So if you think
about 80 relative to,
for example, how many soft
SUSY breaking parameters
you have in the MSSM,
is greater than 100,
then 80 doesn't sound so bad.
Also, you should
remember that, if you're
going to do some
phenomenology with this L2,
that many of the 80 are
not going to contribute.
If you look at a
particular process,
only some small subset
of them will contribute.
And there's many,
many, many observables
in the standard model with
all the different particles.
So 80, once you
start dividing it up
into camps that contribute
to different observables,
is not such a large number.
Or at least it's not
an unmanageable number,
and people do
phenomenology with this.
So for any observable, only a
manageable number contribute.
And I should also say that, if
you have a top-down perspective
where you have a new physics
theory that you've constructed
that has the scale
lambda nu in it,
then from this point of view
what that theory predicts is
a particular
pattern for the c's.
Hopefully, if it has
less parameters than 80,
then you get some patterns of
connections between the c's.
So if you have some new physics
model that has the number
of parameters that
are less than 80,
then you get connections
between these c's.
And you could think that,
if you use this Lagrangian,
constrain the c's, that
you could test generically
for classes of new
physics theories
that are ruled in or ruled out.
Because they have to, if
you match on to these c's
from those theories,
obey whatever constraints
you would derive
from this logic.
Of course, that assumes
that the new physics
particles are at a high scale.
So we can make
this expansion, OK?
Questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
assumption that you
don't have [INAUDIBLE] freedom
is returning to the high order.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you want
them to do a [INAUDIBLE]
or [INAUDIBLE] for high
order, would [INAUDIBLE] they
have to be at
higher [INAUDIBLE]..
And why is it at a higher
energy than [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: So
it's not to say that,
at higher energy, that
no new degrees of freedom
would show up if I really
probe those energies directly.
But what I'm doing is I'm
saying that I'm probing
the physics at small energy.
And the way that high
energy degrees of freedom
would show up is by
a contribution to one
of these operators.
So say I have added in
some new particle at 10
TeV, mass of 10 TeV.
If I expand in momentum
over that mass,
then what will happen is
you'll get an operator
like this O6, where
that particle is
removed because I expanded it.
It got removed.
And its mass will be
exactly in this denominator.
It'll show up here as lambda nu.
So think about it as lambda
nu squared could just
be the propagator.
If I had 1 over p squared
minus some massive--
I don't know, some
gluino, right?
And then I start expanding this.
The first term where I drop
the momentum is just that.
And that could be exactly
this lambda nu squared.
So the new physics particles
don't show up in Oi6.
What they affect
is the pre-factor.
So you don't need to add new
physics particles in order
could construct the operators.
You're just building
those operators out
of the standard model
degrees of freedom.
AUDIENCE: So you're
still working
in p but just [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Yes, yes,
then the lambda nu.
Is there another question?
OK.
So I've been assuming
some familiarity
with the standard model here.
And I've posted also,
as I said last time,
my lecture notes on
quantum field theory 3.
And there's some review
reading there if some of this
is unfamiliar to you, discussing
[INAUDIBLE] and things
like that.
OK.
So what kind of operators
can we have at dimension 6?
I'm not going to list
all 80, obviously,
but I'll list a few of them.
So we could take an operator
that's the following, built out
of gluon field strengths.
So making it Lorentz invariant
and contracting up the indices
and contracting up color
indices with an FABC, that's
an operator that's dimension 6
because the Gs are dimension 2.
That's one of the 80.
You could also do
something with fermions.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what
are the [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: Here?
Whoops.
Yeah, what happened?
All right, there we go.
Thanks.
So here's something with a
lepton doublet and a quark
doublet.
We already introduced
the notation for LL.
And QL is similar,
but just up and down.
So that's each
fermion dimension 3/2.
So four of them
is dimension six.
There's something called
magnetic operators.
So there's lots of
different things
that you can do
with four fermions.
I've only given you one example.
And I've posted the
reference for the paper
that lists all 80.
So you can look
at it if you want
to look at the complete list.
So we can do something where
we have leptons, a Higgs field,
as well as a field
strength for the SU2.
So this is in the SU2.
And these are all
gauge invariant,
as you can convince yourself by
looking at the standard model
gauge transformations
of these operators.
And so if I write something like
this, where this is a doublet
and this is a
doublet and I don't
write the doublet
contraction, then I'm
just contracting those indices.
These two here contribute to
the mu on the magnetic moment,
anomalous moment.
So they contribute to g minus 2.
So g minus 2 at the
muon, which is something
that we've measured
to very high precision
has what sometimes you
would call standard model
contributions,
which people usually
mean as the contributions
in our notation
from L0 and then plus
some contributions
from these higher dimension
operators, whatever
coefficients these
operators have.
And again, I would replace
the Higgs field here
by a [INAUDIBLE].
I know they're
dimension 6, so there's
lambda nu squared downstairs.
One factor of dimension is
made up by the [INAUDIBLE]..
And then the next
scale that comes in
is the mass of the muon.
So this is the generic size
of those contributions.
And again, if you take into
account experimentally how well
we've measured this, it
puts a pretty strong,
or at least it puts a
constraint, on lambda nu.
Actually, it's probably stronger
than this number, some number
greater than 100 TeV.
Maybe it's even 1,000 TeV.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
contribution,
it was [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So the standard
model contribution
makes up all the
digits we've measured.
And then there's some digits
where there's some uncertainty.
We haven't [INAUDIBLE].
And you can constrain, based
on experimental uncertainty,
how big this possible
contribution could be.
And there's 2 and 1/2 deviations
from the standard model
in this observable.
So you can make up for them
with an operator like that.
But I never really pay
attention to things
that are less than
4 sigma personally.
Though sometimes it's
interesting to get
excited about 3 sigma.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: No, I'm not.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So there's also
flavor on top of that.
That's right.
So flavor is actually
highly constrained.
And you could put in some
assumptions about flavor
and then you get
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
So for the remaining 76, see
the reference I've posted.
So this paper actually
wasn't the first to try
to enumerate these operators.
As you can imagine, this would
be a pretty standard thing
to do.
But it was the first to get 80.
And the reason that they got
80 where other people got more
is because they used
the equations of motion
to simplify the operators.
So let me phrase that
as, is there a caveat?
So when they did their
counting of the operators,
they took the equations
of motion from L0,
and they used that
to simplify L1.
So they worked out the standard
model equations of motion
that tree level.
And then they applied
those equations of motion
to reduce the form of
the operators down to 80.
So that got rid of a lot
of operators for them
that other people had
considered as part
of the counting in the past.
So for example-- so
you get some idea,
if I have a covariant
derivative acting
on a right-handed electron.
And the equation of motion
in the standard model
relates that to
[INAUDIBLE] couplings.
Here, I'm writing
the flavor indices
in the left-handed
doublet Higgs field
and the left-handed doublet.
This would be like a mass term
if I put in the [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's like the analog, if I
write it in terms of spinners,
of p slash u for the
right-hand electron is m u,
but just written as
an equation of motion.
So they're using
things like this
to get rid of covariant
derivatives acting
on the right-handed electron and
just replace it by an operator
that a priori doesn't look
like it's equivalent, which
is H dagger L.
Now, if you are stuck at tree
level-- which is actually
the language in which
they constructed
their paper is just
to think that you
apply this in a
way that is valid
when you look at lowest order,
the operators at lowest order.
Then it's pretty obvious,
actually that this is OK.
If the lines that are
coming out of your operator
are always external
lines, then when
you look at the final
rule for those lines,
you're putting them on shell.
So for example, let's think
that we had an operator that
was not part of their list.
So H dagger H e right
id slash e right,
you won't find that as
one of the ones that's
listed in the 80.
You could think about the
Feynman rule for that.
So there's two Higgs
particles, say,
and two right-handed electrons.
And if I just take
the derivative out
of here and then I get a p slash
and if I use p slash as m u,
then I get just u bar u.
And so this is, of
course, connecting us
to the left-handed doublet,
the left-handed guy.
So this operator, in
that sense of thinking
about using the equation of
motion, which are connecting
left and right fields,
putting them together
in the standard model, is
connecting this operator
to the one that we
just have H digger L.
And you could just immediately
get the right result just
by starting with that operator.
And that's the logic
that they used.
So you don't have to write this
down because it's redundant.
You get the same result
from writing this down.
So that seems fairly
straightforward at tree level
and at lowest order where
all the fields are external.
But I actually claim that it's
true regardless of what I do.
Whether I have loops, whether
I have propagators, it's OK.
We can do this.
And that seems a
lot less trivial.
So they didn't know that
when they wrote their paper.
At least I don't think
they did, but it is true.
So that's what I actually
want to talk about
for the rest of today's
lecture because it's
a pretty powerful thing to do.
If we are allowed to use
these equations of motion
to simplify the form of the
higher dimensional operators
in our effective field
theory, it certainly
helps us to reduce the
number of operators.
So one way of phrasing
this is what's
called the representation
independence theorem, sometimes
called that.
I'll phrase it a
few different ways,
but I'll start with this way.
So if we have some
field, phi, we
can set it equal to some
combination of other fields.
So phi and chi can be
scalars, let's say.
And this function, f, which
could be fairly complicated,
has to have at least one
property that, when chi is 0,
it's 1.
So phi and chi both
show up linearly
in some term in the
function if you'd
like, if you want to think
of it as a Taylor series,
for example.
So if that's true, the
statement of this theorem
is that calculations
of observable
that are done with phi or the
Lagrangian that's made of phi--
and what that really means
is that I've quantized phi--
will give the same results
as those with a Lagrangian
where I quantize chi
where I construct
that Lagrangian by just making
this change of variables.
And we're going to
exploit that fact in order
to argue that we're allowed
to do what I just said.
So we'll start slowly,
then we'll build up.
Then we'll state a more
general theorem than this one.
Then we'll show you
how to prove it.
So let's start by
thinking of an example.
Examples are always good.
And we'll stick with
our scalar field theory.
I'm getting tired of
writing factorial,
so I'm choosing a little bit of
different normalization here.
So I'll consider
an effective theory
that has these terms
at least to start.
And eta has dimensions.
And it's a small thing.
It's like 1 over lambda nu.
And the statement that
we want to explore
is the fact that we can
use the equation of motion
to effectively drop
the last term by using
the equation of motion.
So how do we make use
of this statement?
Well, this tells us that we
can make changes to variable
and that we won't
change anything.
So we try to make a change of
variable to make this go away.
AUDIENCE: Wait, sorry.
But that's not even the tree
level operation [INAUDIBLE]
right?
You still have the lambda term.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
I should write the
lambda term in there,
plus, minus, whatever it is.
Thanks.
There's a 2.
All right, so how do we to
get rid of this last term?
Well, let's just use our theorem
by making a field redefinition.
So I claim, after making
this field redefinition here,
that something
magical will happen,
or something that
we want will happen.
So we're going to integrate by
parts at will, which is often
a convenient thing to do when
you're making these field
redefinitions.
So the term that's a 1/2 del mu
phi squared goes to /2 del mu
phi squared from the first term.
And then we pick
up a term that's
exactly in the form we want
to kill this extra term here
that was proportional
to del squared.
And then there would be
order eta squared term.
We have to consistently
make that field redefinition
everywhere, so do it at
the mass term as well.
Well, let me write
out the eta term here,
just a eta squared term just
so you have all the terms.
And we keep doing that.
So we would do it also
for the lambda phi 4 term.
And we do it for
this phi 6 term.
And what you get out when we do
that is that you can write down
the Lagrangian.
And you can group
together the terms.
And that operator is gone.
So it got cancelled by this guy.
There's also these
other things that
are induced, but
really what that
does is it gives you
more terms that are phi 4
and more terms that are phi 6.
So you can really think
of the other terms
as just this guy here
is just adjusting
the constant of the phi 4.
So if it's no longer lambda,
it becomes a term that
has this extra piece to it.
So I'm going to give you more
on this on the problem set.
On the problem set,
you'll work out explicitly
with these relations are.
And I'll also, on
the problem set,
let you think about
what's going on here when
you start considering loops.
In this particular example,
I'll ask you what's going on.
I'll ask you to
show what's going on
and that it's still
OK when we have loops.
So rather than explore this
example in more detail, which
I'm asking you to do
on your problem set,
let's state a more
precise definition
of what we're doing here.
So that's the idea, that I
can make a field redefinition.
When I make a
field redefinition,
it's always going to do
something from the kinetic term
because the kinetic
term is there.
If there's a higher
order term that's
proportional to
that kinetic piece,
then I can set up my
field redefinition
in order to cancel it off.
So there's some things
that are important here.
We have to make a
field redefinition that
preserves symmetry.
So if we make a field
redefinition that
breaks Lorentz
invariance, you can't
expect that you're going
to have a Lorentz invariant
description after that.
And this statement
of f of 0 being 1
is the statement that
you have to preserve
the same one-particle states
before and after the field
redefinition.
And such field redefinition
definitions basically
allow the classical
equations of motion
to be used to
simplify the theory.
I'll also put the proviso
in that it should be
a local quantum field theory.
And there is no
statement in this theorem
that we have to stop
without considering loops
or without considering
propagators that can really
make this argument hold even
beyond the level that we've
showed it, but with loops and
with propagators in as well.
So there's some references.
Again, I've posted
the one that is
closest to our discussion,
which is this paper by Arzt.
There's also a classic
paper by Howard Georgi.
The title of the paper is
"On-Shell Effective Field
Theory."
But I'll mostly follow the
notations in this paper
by Arzt in our discussion here.
We'll go a little
further than he does
and elaborate a little
more, but it's basically
the same notation.
OK.
So how do we prove
something like that?
Well, there are some
lessons in this proof.
So it is something that's
worth going through.
So the way that I set
up my example up there,
I was power counting in eta.
Eta was 1 over lambda nu.
So let me just write our
effective theory organized
as in a series in eta.
And let's consider
removing some operator that
looks like we should
be able to remove it
by making a field redefinition.
And I'll try to be a little
bit generic about what
the form of that operator is.
So I'll say it's covariant
derivative squared
acting on a scalar field just,
again, to make things simpler.
But then multiply
by any function
of all the other fields in the
problem, and that's what t is.
So phi is a complex scalar.
And t is any
function that sort of
meets the needs of our
symmetries of the problem.
And I'm just using
this other phi
as a shorthand for all the other
fields that we might consider.
So that could be fermions,
other scalars, gauge fields.
So let's say we want to get
rid of an operator like that.
Oh, I should also
say that it's local.
All right, well,
let's write down
the generating function for
this theory, path integral
over the fields exponential.
I'll regulate the problem with
dimensional regularization.
It's convenient.
It preserves the cemeteries.
That's something we want to do.
I write out some terms
in the Lagrangian.
We won't need L2.
We'll stop at L1.
But the idea, if we
were to think about L2,
would be similar.
And let me write it as adding
and subtracting something.
So I'll subtract td squared
phi and then add it back.
So this is, if you
like, you can think
that L1 had a td squared phi.
And what I'm doing
here is removing it.
So this is what we want.
OK.
So I'm just making it explicit,
but still writing things
in terms of L1.
So there's that.
And then there's the
coupling to the source.
And kind of in a generic
notation for each field phi k,
I have a source jk.
And I truncate
everything at order eta.
OK, so that's my starting point.
And then Green's functions
are obtained by functional
derivatives with
respect to the j's.
All right, so what
we're going to do,
we're going make a change of
variable in the path integral.
So of course, there's
additional complications
beyond what we were doing when
we were just thinking about it
at Lagrangian level.
There's basically two
additional complications.
When we make a change a
variable in the path integral,
we're going to change
the Lagrangian.
We're also going to
change the measure.
So there could be a Jacobian.
And we have to worry about what
happens with the source term.
So let me just think of it as
a change of variable on the phi
dagger.
That's why I wanted to think
about a complex scalar,
so I could think about
it as phi and phi dagger
and just make the change of
variable in the phi dagger.
But doing a real
scalar is just--
everything would go
through just as well.
So there's one term, which
is the phi dagger term where
there's a Jacobian factor.
So here's that promised
Jacobian for making
that change of variable.
Since the change of
variable is order eta,
it's not affecting L0.
And I can write, in a
kind of nice notation,
the way that these eta
t terms from this change
of variable show up.
I can write them as taking
all the terms in L0,
looking for a phi dagger.
That's the derivative.
And then I replace
it by an eta t.
Now, some places in L0, there
won't be just a straight phi
dagger.
There might be a del
mu phi dagger, right?
So I can take that
into account as well
by taking the functional
derivative with respect
to del mu phi dagger.
So any del mu phi dagger
term, if I integrate by parts,
and then take the
derivative, you
can see why this
is the right form.
Integration by parts is
what gives the minus sign.
OK, so this finds all
the phi daggers in my L0
and sticks in an eta
t to order eta, which
is the order we're working.
So anytime we had in eta,
which is these terms here,
then we would induce
something ordering eta square.
And we're dropping those
terms, so that's not something
we have to worry about.
And then there's the source.
And one of the sources
is 4 phi dagger.
So for that particular
source, j phi dagger,
we induce a term
that's j phi eta t
and then plus order eta squared.
So as I said, there's
three types of changes.
There's a change to the
Lagrangian, like in the example
we did before.
There's a change to the
Jacobian through the Jacobian.
And then there's a change
through the source.
We have to worry about
whether any of these things
will matter.
And basically, what the claim
is and where we're going
is considering the Lagrangian
is actually enough,
so that 2 and 3 are something
that we can kind of deal
with generically.
And then we only have to check
that changing Lagrangian does
what we want.
So the claim is and
what we'll show,
without changing
the s matrix, we
can remove considering 2
and 3 rather generically.
So we don't have to
worry about them.
So some of this we'll
do next time, but let's
just start today.
So let's first
look at del L, kind
of analogous to what we were
doing in our example before.
So what we need is a
change of variable,
which is this one up here.
And one restriction
on del L, which
I mentioned as part
of the assumption,
was that this change of
variable should transform
in the same way as the original
phi dagger, so same Lorentz
index structure, same gauge
index structure, et cetera.
So that's kind of an
assumption that we said.
In order to respect
the symmetries
and not mess them up with
our field redefinition,
we assume that.
So let's see what happens to L0.
So there is L0.
Maybe it has some
other terms as well,
but let's just
consider these pieces
and ask what happens
with them since they're
the relevant ones.
So when I switch to prime
fields, I get that back again.
I get m squared phi
dagger prime phi prime.
And then I get some
new terms, which
I integrate the covariant
derivative by parts,
which I'm always able to do.
It's nice what gauge
symmetry allows you to do.
Then I get a term
like that, and I've
set things up so that this term
here does exactly what we need.
I go back over here.
Those terms are cancelling.
OK, so that's good.
Now, you may be worried about
all the other terms that
get induced.
You've removed something, but
you've induced a lot of stuff.
But the point of
the effective theory
is that you already wrote down
every possible operator that
was consistent with
the symmetries.
So even if you induce
a bunch of other terms,
they should be terms
you already have.
So all you're
doing with inducing
those other terms is shifting
the coefficients of the theory
around.
So L1 was already
complete in the sense
of having all the terms
allowed by the symmetry.
And we've respected the
symmetry in the way we've
made this field redefinition.
So any terms that
I didn't write,
which are all these
terms in the da, da,
da prime are already
operators that
are present in the other
dots that I didn't write.
So there were some dots here.
There was some dots there.
Even if I include
operators in those dots,
the operators in these dots are
already present in those dots.
And so all I'm doing really
is shifting couplings.
OK.
And that's same effective
theory just with a new name
for the coefficients,
but we haven't fixed
the coefficients yet anyway.
We're setting up our
effect effective theory.
So whether we fix
the new coefficients
or the old coefficients,
it's perfectly fine.
So number two is the Jacobian.
And I won't go all
the way through this,
but what are we
going to do there?
We're going to use
the same kind of trick
that we did in gauge theory.
We're going to write the
Jacobian as a Lagrangian
involving ghosts.
So remember, when you
talked about Faddeev-Popov
in some field theory
course prior to this one,
you saw that you could write a
determinant as an exponential
involving some ghost fields.
And the way that it worked
is that, up to a sign,
whatever was sitting here
ended up just sitting
between the ghost fields.
So this is the ghost of
Faddeev-Popov procedure.
And we're going to just
use the same thing,
although [INAUDIBLE] we're
talking about scalar field
theory.
So for us, we take this
guy, which is the Jacobian,
I'll take that derivative.
And if you take
this thing, which
is sitting in
functional determinant,
and you turned it into
ghosts, then what you get
is a terminal Lagrangian
that looks like that.
So that looks like it
could do something.
And I think I'll take
this up next time.
It turns out that
this term is actually
a ghost that has mass that's
of order the high scale, lambda
nu.
And so, again, because of our
logic of the effective theory
only being valid
below that high scale,
we can just effectively
integrate out this ghost.
And then it shifts
coefficients again,
but I'll continue
with that next time.
So we have to figure out what to
do with this ghost Lagrangian.
And we'll deal with
that next time.
So any questions about
our halfway done proof?
No?
OK.
So this is a pretty
powerful thing
that you can use in
effective field theory.
And it also keeps
your eye on the ball
because it tells you
to think about physics.
Because this leaves
physics invariant.
It doesn't leave
something like if you--
say you had a theory that
had some long distance
degrees of freedom.
And it had some short
distance potential.
The short distance
potential could be changed
by a field redefinition.
It might not be
a physical thing.
It keeps your eye on the
ball as to what is physical
and how to talk about things.